[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever you want
was that part of a bit yes very relevant
I feel like this is gonna be going on
for like the next like three or four
months anyways uh-huh if you can
continue to buy a hand sanitizer it's
all sold out everywhere making their own
but it's okay we'll talk about that
later all you got this being on with you
yeah mine with you as well and Gina and
thank God we balanced it out to light
skin yeah you know time to change what
kind of magic is gonna happen didn't I
tell you look it's gonna be a lot of
rhythm it's gotta be an episode steam is
pretty ethnic yeah he's definitely a
wild cord like if you plan he can be
higher low because he can float the Lena
crowd totally agree I've been told I'm
very urban quite a bit you have not been
too much I was gonna take you with me to
like the B et Awards or something should
be how about I think you know oh please
very urban oh my god so so wait can't
say yesterday so I I told I said I don't
know if I ever said to like I worked at
a concert coming for and they [ __ ] my
first day there they tell me they're
like they're verbage for black concerts
is urban heard this it's so fun boy it
is for nightclubs - it's like when I
used to work the nightlife so it was
[ __ ] ranks by like nightclub so in the
hot you and I Club opens up it's white
people first they get they get the club
first and then when it dies down then
it's Asian people and then it's urban
even even the comedy clubs like the
urban night used to be Tuesday nights at
the Comedy Store in urban night at the
Laugh Factory in Hollywood is chocolate
sundaes appropriate say what should they
call a name in that chocolate sundae
even imagine being a confused black
person at a Keith Urban concert when he
comes out you're like wait I thought it
was
yeah no this isn't it I don't know what
the alternative is can I get what the
alternative is no just the other didn't
just say in Black Knight yeah at the
club just come out better than being
tattooed chicks that just call you
alternative period or like there's a
marquee and it just says bring in the
blacks I'm like imagine they call the
Oriental Knights a yellow fever night
I'm get to come kiss yellow fever we
bring our own fortune cookies to the
party thank you that would be so [ __ ]
what have they were giving that out at
the door oh my god okay here's your
fortune cookie have a great time yeah
and then here's an ill with my way boy
crackers just be like that like the
crackers because they know flavor
anything like that and then they go
hello wait what scoffs to have like
living to limit so there then they go
Oreo for you sir I know like a whole
last cone shot it would be like three
talkies are they delicious yes like them
better than the regular sakis because we
don't have the two as much yeah
who owns pockys who what race is that
Japanese Japanese Japanese cut the check
oh you know what I want that but in
English I mean it is well you know black
people like Japanese so I was like let
me Kevin
have you been to Japan we're like this
they just have like random black guy
standing in front of Urban stores yeah
but these were they doing they're late
there's like oh come on in it's like oh
cool black guy in black people clothes
so they just have people standing there
but I like that cuz I feel like it'd be
hard for me to get a job in Japan yeah
oh yeah I know that I can understand I
will say that in Tokyo I got one of the
best haircuts I had ever gotten in my
life and it was fun yeah yeah hehe and
they're like they were playing wu-tang
in the barbershop like it was literally
a black barbershop but with all japan
working like japanese workers like and
they was like fade in and it was it was
amazing I was blown away I was like I do
cope with these guys pretty so I made it
the best cut just the detail you put
into it the time with the towel and
everything and then for the price point
like it would have been the equivalent
of like a $30.00 haircut here well it
would have been the equivalent of paying
$30 here but it was like a $75
experience so like that's why I go to
like hammer nail to get my manicure
pedicure is hammer and nail it's like a
meal yes I'm it's a man spot so like you
go in you get you get a drink we first
first go ahead and give you whiskey
vodka whatever so like they have
different pedicures and manicures like
you get a classic pedicure or classic
manicure I get the tea tree oil pedicure
where they like threw out the tea tree
oil on your your cuticles puts the
cuticles back and they clip you put in
water Sookie and massage her legs and
hit me with the hands we love a man to
take care of himself that Steve did it
because his hands are so goddamn soft I
have something that's just cuz he's
never worked the bed is like he's what
yeah I don't want sure he did work for
printer income woody Oh Medicare they
already know dirt underneath
I like your feet I do sharp contrast to
Joe Jessica was toast
Oh Bart's toes bars are weighted aborts
those can make me throw up
wait
Nellore the toes just going all over its
everything going on around like a black
flap of skin fungus on his toe finding
Michael had to suck it on JK party you
know and I was like I almost straight up
well hey you know what you know what you
know what that he didn't have to come on
man
yeah I've been pressure to do a lot of
stuff that I didn't do that did not have
- absolutely not - or weight to be my
corns on his feet - yeah yeah Jo have
everything I mean if you break the pace
go down by the hour Michael Pitt got me
like 15 bucks of sub Jo stuff maybe he's
an experienced guide to that reason
though because of all things happen to
Michael he is it up retaliating once he
got it like once he took charge of
coming up with the challenges and stuff
or a JQ party and that's what he would
make us do the worst thing somebody has
to eat hair shake you had like just one
piece all like it Oh a little ball and I
had to chew it for like 30 seconds Oh
Shane Dawson's burger one time why yeah
but you guys chose two boogers in front
of me for a challenge like a burger
challenge and it was like a wet woman I
got huge ride out of your brain nowadays
no that was back in the wind
nowadays somebody probably would pay for
that experience for that anything to get
me closer
yeah I think so I just pull a gag first
all you did was like arm yourself with
his defenses for allergies like that's
what boogers are good for like kids
don't get well a lot of kids will stay
healthy by eating boogers because my
boogers when I was a kid and I never did
in school cuz there's embarrassing but
man
that's honestly disgusting how do you
out eat my friends burgers not not as a
grown-ass man yeah thank you thank you
man I thought the gang I could pick my
nose I picked my nose a lot but I judged
the kids that ate it I always always
flunk me too me too
that was me fling it wipe it do not eat
it I'm self-sufficient okay it's like an
old cycle comes out goes back in no
that's not eaten in the bathroom in and
out
wait no so question what exactly is a
booger is it formulated by like snot
into the nose hairs that coagulate into
a bean wagga described a booger yeah
that basically is it yeah okay so that's
how it works yeah so theoretically
speaking if I were to get rid of all of
my nose hairs what I have boogers oh you
would
yes over there the mess with that ma'am
Jesus um so on my stream I made a
donation goal that if you donated this
much I will wax my nose hair and I
watched my nose hairs you know
everything drips a lot yeah there's
nothing holding it back this is a
defense it's a lot easier I when I got
my [ __ ] west okay seems like
everything drips a lot it's just way
easier way yeah wait he's like velcro
and it holds it all together yeah yeah
way to clean a white there was this one
comedian talking about how like every
man should shave his butthole because
he's like that's disgusting like think
about it there's [ __ ] on a carpet rug
and then you wipe that with the dry
toilet paper that's not gonna clean
anything so at least like because he was
like I always use a bidet or like a wet
way which is wet like yeah yeah but like
cleaning [ __ ] out of hair is disgusting
yeah everyone should shave their bus
dude I think that everyone should shave
their ball at least once just because
your ma hole is the softest skin on your
body it like that little crevice in the
area it is so soft find me another's
body I thought it was underneath your
eye no dude areolas are really soft are
they true
it's the same skin as the areola but
with no creases it's just smooth oh
that's creases when you get close to
that like that region that's world you
get a lot of like crazy no creases in
your bus you do Botox your bum s mo o ve
smooth it's like somebody facetune that
[ __ ] you yeah absolutely it's got a
little it's got like a little pucker and
then it just and then it's just smooth I
don't have the starfish man I do but it
goes out y'all look like they live huh
petite but I'm gonna cry my balls like
this my balls like this open yeah he's
pretty he's pretty open every for a
chisel he's very down my farts are like
the sound of bubbles like oh well back
to shave your butthole as though you
can't or do you guys actually shave your
balls I absolutely know what are you
used to shave your balls I actually use
manscape I have an amazing pocket so
shout outs to manscape our sponsor for
this episode well did you guys know that
that bushes are out and clean it happens
to be in because because nobody really
likes bush anymore deal with it girls
yeah we love a smooth boy yeah he needs
anymore
girls need to deal with it because they
were super into guys with mega mega bush
and now guys are cleaning up out there
we're shaving it down yeah girls need to
accept it or [ __ ] get over it and
move on with mega Bush group or just uh
nevermind no I was a girly girls were
obsessed with guys having the David
Hasselhoff but down low right heavy
heavy heavy but now we're done with it
we're cleaning it up down there I like
it you take control of your old body
thank you very much yeah and so and
that's why manscaped has helped us
because they have redesigned the
electric trimmer
they got 7,000 rpms in this [ __ ]
this thing is gonna
to clean balls like your balls never
clean your life you're gonna wonder if
maybe your balls are being cleaned with
too much power LED light on it so you
could see everything that you're doing
and the battery lasts up to 90 minutes
so if you take a long time shaving well
you don't have to worry about the
battery less or going out how do take a
long time I light a candle do you use
the LED light that absolutely because I
like to shave in the dark that's right
me since I saving the dark I stay away
the best angles and I see by candlelight
okay actually helps me a lot
that's what LED comes in yeah it's a spa
days you really can't see like all
because like when you're standing and
you're trying to get underneath like
they're still shadows being cancer by
everything yeah so the LED really really
comes ahead lawnmower 3.0 LED because I
got the [ __ ] flickering candle light
and I'm like you know it's kind of on
and off yeah but the LED lights a steady
stream of light that helps me I am a big
fan I'm a big shaving process is very
romantic thank you yeah everything I do
is will matter
I made the guy so you don't get 20% off
with free shipping with the code off the
record at manscape comm that's 20% off
with Free Shipping at manscape common
user code off the record so cheers to
manscaping your lucky charms cuz you
guys know st. Patrick's Day is coming up
so you want to make sure you're nice and
clean so you could get lucky and get her
to your goal you light that sack up with
manscape I want you to shave it into a
four-leaf clover so I know that I'm
getting lucky tonight oh hey huh Burke
out the leaves
real talk I had long ass hairs because
I would shave like the vagina read the
vulva if you will and I thought like oh
yeah is super smooth but I didn't know
how far back the hairs move cuz my butt
is like it's closed like it's very like
there's a lot of cushion right oh yes
there's like they were a long ass hairs
like bangs at like it's curled like I
literally will not picturing other than
is coming out of the technique is to put
one of those hand mirrors on the floor
squat over it oh that's like a
Vietnamese way to Squatch is hollows
I've only ever like put a Mary down
there and looked at myself maybe like
three times a mile what I used to be
obsessed I can draw my [ __ ] out of
memory the first found out that it
looked like that under there cuz you
know what health class they show you
picture of the vagina I was like it
doesn't look like that it's just a crack
and then I look down there with the
mirror I was like geez that and then
after that every time before I took a
shower I would look at it like guys do
that all the time because they do the
big toe snap when you it's like the
generic dick picture when you put the
camera on the floor and you like take
your dick out and you hit the
I'll just shoot from underneath my thigh
I just come underneath my thigh
everything pans if you put if you put
the phone on the floor and then just hit
the button with your big toe it's like a
whole different type of angle and it
just does have more effort I just have a
really decent for you and then I like
the smile too so like it was that looks
weird if you see a dip and a dick thing
a test is amazing guys what a beautiful
job more personal charming dick and
personality the same insane form you
don't get that a lot though that's what
I'm saying so I never send dick pics
that's in ditches
that's my problem in porno this guy's
she sends you a text back and she's like
is this a portrait mode I always get the
lazy ones in my DM soon it's always the
one where you just like no this is like
this but then they hold it the base
[Music]
never look at those anymore because I'm
Instagram blurs exactly Instagram blurs
it so if I know it's a dick pic I'm not
gonna like unblurred and look at it but
recently I had um so you know have when
you when you all put repost someone on
your stories and they pop up in your
inbox yeah and then like now you they
could pop up in your inbox yeah I wish
they would take that away like no turn
off the messaging you know same but
anyway so then this one guy that I
previously had responded to a long time
ago recently sent me something and I was
like oh what'd they say cuz I'm like I
couldn't tell it was a guy cuz of the
username and the
were these like different things an
anime character yeah so then um so I end
up clicking on it and then I see it's
his [ __ ] dick like he it was one of
these work you could see his face and
like it was like a little bunch of like
roles and stuff you know like was he
grimacing unflattering huh was a
grimacing like you just work yeah
because even he knows so before I open
the photo though the actual message was
really sweet it said something about
like oh yours later like you're still so
pretty on some other [ __ ] so then yours
later you're still so pretty Chris
macaque respond did I take the do this
but I responded I'm like really man wide
like don't make me go Gina on you like
[ __ ] be respectful dude this is
disgusting effort I feel like it to dig
that's why you need to don't ever send
unsolicited dick pic right that's number
one they wanted them they were always as
well you've decorated your dick well
enough so that it doesn't look like a
penis look if you send it if you send a
girl a picture of you holding our thing
of roses but actually one of them is
your dick that's pretty good then she
doesn't necessarily even know she's seen
your dick yeah and that's what I think
is great I mean I think just take more
effort like a lot of guys everything
like early morning depicts because it's
like you think it's the hardest but like
you don't put no lotion or like honestly
if you send a dick picture and the penis
is completely dry like you've really
missed out on an object drop never see a
pili dick no but actually a hot tip for
all you weenie whippers out there the
way the Instagram sends us the photos
you know it's like pixelated it's
pixelated so it condenses the pixels and
it makes your penis look like death be
big it makes it look like did be so stop
sending unsolicited quick the less
they're creatively covered up like
thieves and I'll appreciate you're gonna
get a bunch of creative yeah you're
somebody's gonna be lined up like remote
screwdriver dick ruler that's all you
got to do new [ __ ] I wanted to get one
for the holidays like every major
holiday green big I do I have green a
lot of green dick I'm in a video I did
like because someone asked about like do
I like getting dick pics and I answered
it in a video and I was like I just have
seen a lot of dicks it's does nothing to
me it doesn't turn girls on like we said
you see the dick you seen them all and I
was like it's no different than seeing
like a candle and then I got a bunch of
candle picks and I [ __ ] love that or
not turned on by dick pics unless they
like you guys when they like you they
definitely want to see you dick
but you will know but when they like you
and when they want to see you did you
send an unsolicited dick pic would be
the equivalent of you sending a picture
of a time like hey hey what you think it
is time like the [ __ ] tire you
pervert I'm looking for a tire I'm like
oh why that's a nice tire yeah I need
that tire you ever all so [ __ ] hard
to read so how am I gonna know if you
like me or not yeah marry third he's
still a star I had a guy that I started
talking to early in LA cuz when you said
this was just reminded me of that and he
he said something funny to me one time
made me laugh out loud and then I lose
you back on my channels like alright let
me see it no they will let you know I
did that they said something funny and
you were just like let me see you [ __ ] I
gotta watch comedians man you'd be
laughing and boom they see you know
you're [ __ ] a dick we look for laughs
daddies at the comedy club I'll be out
there lady he's laughing his way into
your butthole yeah
[Music]
[Music]